evil morning fan theories I have never
read a single one of them
I let fan theories trickle back to me
because you've got a room full of
writers you chitchat there are people
who are less afraid than me of going
into the subreddit so I sometimes things
get back to me about like certain
theories about Rick and Morty in general
and then I imagine there's a million
evil wordy theories now is the time for
action
[Music]
we have fan theories of our own in the
writers room
they're called ideas that go in a
shoebox like we have these discussions
but we don't we don't decide anything
that becomes canon until until we have
to
I don't consume record Marti fan
theories because that would be a bad
idea what if I saw a theory that was
real it would eliminate me being able to
do something that I was cooking up
because I'd go well that person guessed
it and even worse like well do you want
me to steal your fan theory and use it
as an idea I digress if you liked the
show keep watching it if you don't like
the show force yourself to keep watching
it whether you watch the show or not buy
some of the merchandise and if you make
the show share some of that
merchandising money hey everybody its
charlie so Dan Harmon just did a big
interview for season four he talked
about a bunch of stuff but I just wanted
to cherry pick some of the more
interesting bits so obviously there's
him talking about evil Morty I just did
a video on them talking about clone Beth
so I'll link that at the end of this but
if you've been listening to the season 3
DVD commentaries they do talk about
where they are in terms of the ongoing
mysteries that they've left open to
resolve either in season 4 or future
season there are 70 episodes now so it's
not like they have to wrap everything up
right away but if you're finding me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get all the rick and morty videos I'm
doing a season 3 DVD giveaway - all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video I named a new winner at the end of
this I don't think it's too much of a
surprise to anyone that he doesn't spend
a lot of his time poring over fan
theories it's really bad from a legal
standpoint like the lawyers at Turner
will tell him don't read that because
some fan will claim that you stole their
idea so as he says though in the writers
room they have a lot of their own
theories about how these are gonna pan
out
clone Beth evil Morty but if you
remember - this season 2 finale
everybody had all kinds of crazy
theories about how they were gonna break
him out at the beginning of season 3 you
get to the season 3 episode 1 and he
just blew right past it like nope we're
not gonna do that storyline we're done
with that anyway that's how I escaped
from space prison Oh scary place Wow
Rick that's one heck of a story I sure
do wish I could
there been a couple times on the DVD
commentaries and in interviews where Dan
and Justin have each said that they tend
to favor standalone stories over heavy
serialization like they don't mind
serialized elements like evil Morty's a
good example that where you kind of
string him along like once or twice per
season but from a practical standpoint
they're trying to sell the show into
syndication in standalone episodes tend
to sell better in syndication so on the
back end from a business perspective it
just proves them not to serialize things
too much but because evil Morty has
become such a big cultural thing since
season 3 he's been built up more than
zebes and floorp is the big bad of the
series assuming that Rick doesn't wind
up being the big bad of the series
himself if you're thinking about the
Breaking Bad model they're having a lot
of Breaking Bad references when Rick
creates the house from the fake memory
it's the house from Breaking Bad so you
do have to consider that as powerful as
evil Morty seems you know in a
traditional model you would expect him
to be the big bat of the series the
final boss might wind up being c-137
rick having to defeat himself there was
a clip during the last video that I
posted where Justin talks about doing 14
episodes per season so I am assuming
that they're shooting for 14 episodes
for whatever the remainder of these 7d
are which winds up being about five more
years of Rick and Morty if they can get
a new season out every single year so
that would definitely increase the
likelihood of evil Morty coming back but
I'm still only expecting him maybe like
once next season chances are even pretty
good that they could just hold him off
till season 5 - if they wanted but if
they're doing 14 episodes per season
that's a lot of story to tell the last
we saw of him he was co-opting The
Citadel and all the other Rick's of the
central finite curve using their
influence so early prediction they
stretched that idea out over the next
couple of seasons and in between that
c-137 Rick and Morty wind up just
bumping into agents of evil Morty
without directly engaging him till they
get to some sort of final conflict like
for the next season or two you just see
evil Morty's symbol in his banner start
popping up in other realities outside of
the Citadel like Oh evil Morty has been
here he's been busy doing things in the
background so you don't have to bring
him back on screen but you can still
invoke him in stories another really
good example of them holding on to
characters is the president at the end
of the season three finale
so you basically have the same version
of Rick in the president just hitting
the reset button on the relationship
under the pretense that it's a different
version of Rick because c-137 has
supposedly left the planet the
commentary on that was kind of funny too
like the whole idea that the president
had an idea that it was still the same
Rick I mean I don't the only purpose
that would have served is to just
clarify that that was Rick and the cup
and the president knew and they're
playing this like we're gonna we're
gonna both just play dumb on this and
it's easier for our egos so they just
call it square so I definitely think the
Keith David will come back as the
president maybe not right away but Keith
David will also probably come back to do
other characters to like remember
reversed giraffe look he's just really
awesome as a voice actor so you want to
have him back even if he's not gonna be
playing the really big characters that
he played in previous seasons so 70
episodes let me know what do you think
the odds are for them not bringing evil
Marty back right away in waiting to way
down the road to have a really big
battle between him and Rick or even
better yet what do you think they're
gonna do with Phoenix person and Tammy
because they implied that they just kind
of broke that as a really funny ending
without really intending on bringing
them back in a big way I really love the
idea of Tammy and Phoenix person out
there and and I have all this stuff I
want to talk to you Harmon about and you
just about Tammy and how she works and
stuff and ladies whether or not she
comes back who gives a I just have
some cool ideas about because listening
to the DPD commentaries it sounds like
they just wrote that as a funny ending
without really having a solid idea for
what they wanted to do with them in the
future and not really intending on
turning it into a big serialized thing
like Rick and the president or Rick and
evil Morty very different story after
that first episode like you see them set
something like that up and you kind of
assume they intend to pay it off down
the road but then you listen to them
talk about it and they're like oh no
they never intended to pay that off they
were just doing a funny thing so they
bring them back they might just be doing
something funny in a standalone story oh
and for people that are wondering there
were some quotes in the interview that
Dan Harmon did that made it sound like
he hasn't started working on season four
yet you have to remember that the
interview that he did was conducted
months ago before they finished
negotiating the new
so they are actually working on it but
one thing at a time so we'll probably
hear more about what stage they're in
when we get to comic-con
but congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Tyler Houston please
private message me so I can get your
contact details click here to listen to
that other video with them talking about
you know mystery 14 episodes and clone
Beth and click here for brand new
Avengers for Hulk thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]